the caravan hit the fan or rather a
parade of unchecked immigrants hit a
wall in orange wall a 71 year old
cheeseburger eating wall that is that is
Donald Trump his blunt response to a
planned symbolic wave of immigrants from
Honduras created what we call second
thoughts and the caravan became a
caravan somewhere in Mexico
yep they called Trump's bluff and he
said enough but were they really coming
anyway who knows but what a slam-dunk
4dt seriously the guys put all over
illegal immigration forever
and an activist group says hey while
he's president let's send a thousand
people to the border not happening so
here was an example of the new school
being schooled by the old school an
old-world dude faced off with the modern
grievance movement and the movement
moved on reminds me of a movie in a
world where the border is Wallace and
the boundary is lawless they sent a
caravan and he sent an army we're gonna
be guarding our water with the military
it's a small step for man that's a big
step sorry it's a big step
when federal law was left unenforced and
Democrats kicked the can down the road
where is it the ball down the field
either way one man said nah bro not in
my country nude man on unicorn thinkin
the cake while reciting Shakespeare
backwards films presents Donald Trump
Enrique Pena Nieto and Ric Flair as the
nature for executive action 11 order at
the border
now there's another reason there's
another reason why the caravan failed
society society's biggest beef is always
lying cutting which is predicated on
fairness if you're not in dire need
then you wait in line like everyone else
the many many thousands of people here
in my studio audience right now they
waited they waited in line yeah the
thousands waited in line but it seems
we've forgotten why so here's a primer
even kids will understand line cutting
why is it bad well first you should know
that lines are as American as the
Revolutionary War back then linear
infantry formations would have to wait
their rightful turn before shooting each
other with muskets in fact four out of
five scientists agree without lines we
never would have won our independence
fast-forward to today and you can see
lines everywhere for iPhones at
ballgames one Gordon Ramsay's forehead
and there's even a line to get into this
country the only place you won't see
lines are at maroon 5 concerts but some
people like to cut the whole thing
leaving those people who followed the
rules out in the cold doesn't seem fair
does it unless of course you're in a
place that says rules don't matter and
you're given sanctuary but that's a
video for another time and that is why
line cutting is bad
[Music]
[Applause]
no one explains it the bottom line
everyone who came here the right way
wishes everyone else would do the same
thing get in line
meanwhile the left met another wall call
it a collusion collision after a year of
very thorough investigation and going
after all the low-hanging fruit if they
couldn't have shifted him from a subject
to a target there's nothing there now
they're going after very very weak
issues collusion I challenged Muller to
tell me what statute is violated by
collusion ah der sir wits throwing down
the gauntlet
so was the news that Trump's not a
target a +4 Trump and a setback for his
foes at CNN we stopped by their offices
for comment
[Applause]
so where is the impeachment Caravan now
heading into another wall no surprise I
mean have they even thought this thing
through
seriously what happens if the
impeachment imps get exactly what they
want what do they end up with
[Music]
that's your plan I love that plan
replace a centrist Republican with a guy
who's so right-wing he makes Genghis
Khan look like grandpa Walton but the
left never has a plan always seeking to
replace things that work a free-market a
border a president with crap communism
socialism identity politics patchouli
tofu no wonder everything they touch
ends in suffering if history was our
guide we'd build a wall around them but
last and never least there's this a
former first lady compares Donald Trump
to being a bad parent the eight years
that Barack was president it was sort of
like having the the good parent at home
the one that told you to eat your
carrots and go to bed on time and now
perhaps we have the other parent maybe
it feels fun to some for now because we
can eat candy all day and you know stay
up late and not follow the rules that
wasn't a bad metaphor except for the
last line it feels fun for now because
we can eat candy all day so what's the
candy is it more jobs less Isis progress
with North Korea Gorsuch tax cuts
because if that's the candy what does
that make Donald Trump
again and
[Music]
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guest he's like
James Bond but with better hair former
CIA officer [ __ ] sex dad like falling
through a plate-glass window
he'll leave you in stitches comedian Joe
Mackey
she's only cheerful when she has a beer
full national review reporter cat Tim he
can literally move mountains impact
wrestler in my massive sidekick Tyrus
so buck I have to hand it to Donald
Trump on this because this was a yearly
political stunt by an activist group to
raise awareness about asylum seekers and
so so forth and it's been done before
but he repurposed it for his law and
order perspective and it seems like it
works I don't know we also have more
data now about what ends up happening by
the way you have a lot of 25 year old
showing up at the border saying they're
17 yeah it's just now been established
I've been tripping like that by the way
they tell me they're 25 so wait so
there's a lot of that that happens and
also what I think people started to
recognize this week is that they're
actually not illegals yeah they were
going through this is a caravan going
through a mountain sized loophole this
was an enormous loophole where they
literally show up to Border Patrol and
they say here we are can you put us on
those buses and send us to the places
where you give the people the free place
to stay and the food yeah and tell me to
show up in immigration court in about
five years yes we'll see how that goes
good point Joe I think this was poor
planning on their part here you have a
president who's so old-world all law and
order they go let's just send a thousand
people to the border he won't do
anything yeah caravans a terrible way to
sneak into a country unless it's a Dodge
Caravan I've said that a million times
I'll say again well tell you what they
were upset that about the presidential
election in Honduras I don't think that
they're gonna like the president here
Trump probably wouldn't done well in
that election yeah cats I kind of what
bums me out about the caravan it's
actually an important issue people
trying to get out of bad countries but
you how can just being a man just being
a citizen of a country make you an
asylum seeker there's got to be like war
and pestilence in hell right thank you
guess that wasn't much of a question I
look I think that the one issue had with
this is Trump said this represented like
a massive influx yeah illegal immigrants
when really Border Patrol agents have
said this is pretty typical of what they
see every day yeah and also border
crossings have dropped dramatically
there's not this new massive influx and
I do think that Trump does
credit for that I think he's giving
himself enough credit there they've
dropped dramatically so there's not this
new massive wave their way down yeah but
it is it's part I think it's because
he's a metaphorical wall
I mean Whitley like if somebody who just
gets elected says you're not gonna
you're not allowed to come here it's
gonna send people back right Tyra sir
yeah I think it was interesting because
we live in a world where now what no
one's ever really beaten or loses an
argument and they were pretty much told
you're not coming to America is there
like beautiful Tijuana we are now going
to beautiful Tijuana ladies and
gentlemen Tijuana where everyone gets a
fresh start you know man it's amazing
over there it's kind of like America
just drunker yeah it'll be great so why
do spaces that this sure it'll be a but
get Morgan Freeman the narrator now in
Tijuana where they partner do life so I
didn't really lose I can't give it you
know he sent the National Guard and
they're like maybe gonna do clerical
work nah brother not cleric and nothing
they're just they're clicking and
clacking and making sure you're not
crossing but yeah that was the the whole
thing the days they changed the
narrative to where it was just a
symbolic right except they didn't tell
the people on the buses who packed
everything they could possibly could and
underneath the bus and they didn't tell
them there was just a it's just a little
thing they're gonna show off and
everyone's gonna go back to Honduras ya
know they're stuck in Tijuana now and
it's not a lot of jobs out there yeah
there are a lot of jobs but they're not
jobs that you wanted yeah apparently I
would not do that all right so what's
final questions if nothing seems to be
working buck well you you what you're
they're going with collusion doesn't
work and stormy doesn't work and
infidelity doesn't wear a collusion that
dementia what it what should the left do
now to win the midterm election yes it
does not be crazy but I can't manage to
do that I really like if they actually
focus they know what the answer is here
yeah because of what happened in
Pennsylvania or lamb if they talk about
issues that actually matter to the
American electorate they have a chance
of winning some of those toss-up races
that right now are actually trying a
little bit Democrat but if they do what
you're talking about you cannot turn on
CNN without seeing either Vladimir
Putin's face or stormy day yes that is
that does become the network mantra
right they got to put them together
stormy Putin stormy Putin that sounds
this that sounds like a medical disorder
Joe final thoughts on how things are
going in general maybe we could get katy
perry out there on the campaign trailer
earlier this year yeah she wasn't she
really helped don't you think i from
some people's perspective yes mainly not
hers